[Music]
three other games were played this
weekend even though we have focused
exclusively almost exclusively on eagles
bears the other game on sunday chargers
ravens 23-17 la wins in baltimore
running their record when playing away
from los angeles this year to nine and
oh because they had that playoff win
they had seven road wins away from la
they had one of the road games in the
coliseum they had a home game in london
so the chargers have no problem getting
on a plane and traveling somewhere and
winning football games they'll do it
again this weekend when they go to new
england but
chris you know we've now seen a team get
a second crack at the ravens throwback
offense and that second time around they
were able to shut down lamar jackson
they went with seven defensive backs the
entire game lamar jackson was stymied
through three quarters we went for a
period of time in the third quarter
where we thought he was going to be
benched for joe flacco he turned it on
in the fourth quarter but it was too
little too late as the ravens tried to
pull off what would have been an
incredible comeback down 23-3 final
score 23-17
the the the chargers now i look i mean
we've been taking them seriously all
year do you see anything from yesterday
that that makes you think this isn't a
team that can compete for a super bowl
no not at all i mean they're one of the
complete teams in the in the afc one of
the most complete teams i should say in
afc you know i i i picked them to win
yesterday and i'm not trying to pat
myself on the the back or anything but
i'm sure no no my point is i picked him
to win because of what i saw on film
during the late last week when i went
back and watched the matchup itself the
first time around and i came away coming
that game going man the chargers didn't
get pushed around like i thought they
did on tv you know the game unfolded the
first matchup where yes the first few
drives the ravens had success running
the ball but after that it was tough
sledding and i thought that the chargers
might be able to uh continue that
success and we've we see once again that
it's just so hard for a team that's
one-dimensional to win football games in
the playoffs and even though we all had
great hope that the ravens might be able
to do it just hey lamar jackson still
needs to improve as a pocket passer he
had a rough day yesterday all the
fumbled exchanges and things that went
on early in the game that really set up
the chargers to win the football game
and really dictate the flow of the
football game and how it went from there
on out but to your point mike the
chargers are dangerous and any four of
these teams in the afc can win this
weekend and go to the super bowl i think
that's why it's such an awesome year
from the nfl
we had said last week that
number one the chiefs and the patriots
are very happy the ravens and chargers
are playing each other because one of
them gets knocked out number two neither
the chiefs nor the patriots want to see
the winner of that game but if you're
the chiefs right is it really a better
outcome to have the colts coming to town
by the way that they have been playing
they've now won 10 of their last 11.
they've won in houston twice in roughly
a month yeah how and you know
and again i don't want to get too far
out of myself here we're going to be in
kansas city so we have to survive there
for a couple of days i want to i don't
want to go out on a limb and say i like
the colts because i still right now
think the chiefs hold serve so and i am
saying that for selfish interest because
we do have to be there for two days but
if i'm the chiefs i don't think i want
any part of this colts team right now
they're dangerous uh as any team in the
playoffs right now confidence right
they're young they don't even know the
situation they're in they're just going
we're playing football having fun their
defense flies around they're well
coached uh you know eberflus has done a
great job with that defense but i think
you know the more important aspect and
where this game gets scary for the
chiefs or anybody that plays the colts
but especially the chiefs the chiefs are
a lot like the houston texans okay where
their past defense stinks i mean it's
horrible and they rely on their front
four to get pressure and this is the
worst team to play in football right now
with that type of formula because the
indianapolis colts and that o-line will
give andrew luck all day long to throw
the football and they're just he'll sit
there and wait for t.y hilton to get
open and eric ebron to get open and
they're going to create mismatches with
some of these people in the kansas city
chief secondary that's where it's going
to be really dangerous and i think
that's where you know this game has the
chance to be
that high-flying shootout i'm not going
to say like we saw with rams chiefs but
i wouldn't be shocked that this is 40-37
or 44-41 type of game whatever
quarterback has at last
the the cults are extremely dangerous
and confident right now
there's a history between these teams in
the postseason as well a few years ago
it was the colts down 38 to 10 to the
chiefs at home yeah and the colts came
back and won and i recall a game
when dick vermeel i think was coaching
the chiefs peyton manning was the colts
quarterback
and they were having such a hard time
stopping the cults i think they started
kicking on side after they scored do you
remember that i i think it's like we've
got no chance to stop indianapolis so
let's just try to keep possession by
doing it on sidekick i think i do
vaguely remember that yes uh and uh i do
believe that the colts won the game that
day as well now hey this is a different
team in kansas city than years past you
know this is it's a whole i know they've
had playoff home struggles and all those
things and the cults are a good football
team but with patrick mahomes at
quarterback they're just different
because they can put pressure on you and
even if you jump out by 14 20 points
we've seen the chiefs can close that gap
in a hurry because of their explosive
plays on offense sammy watkins health
for the kansas city chiefs is going to
be paramount for me and whether they can
make a super bowl run because i don't
expect their defense to make a lot of
stops they are going to have to win
shootout style and outscore people and
they're paying sammy watkins odell
beckham jr money and they need him to
come out there and play and be available
for the playoffs
yeah and the chiefs have not won
a home playoff game since joe montana
was the starting quarterback and that is
a narrative that is not going to go away
until they win
you remember who he beat
was it the steelers it was good job it
was steelers late touchdown over time
yeah over time that was overtime yeah i
think he scored a late touchdown to tie
it and then they won in overtime right i
think i may be wrong yeah because i
often am yes i think that that was the
same day the giants and the vikings got
together in the meadowlands on a day
when it was very very windy and the
vikings actually got the ball to start
each half and went three and out and the
giants scored easy touchdowns that was
after that was after phil's time so you
probably weren't at the game no let's
see wait no that was the year that was
phil's last year i believe wasn't that
93 that was the 93 wildcard game phil
was there you were there yeah he he won
that game and crapped all over your
minnesota vikings so deal with that
yeah
i know that was the same day though
i think it was the same day because i i
was you know those memories that linger
the old tv set that was like the tube
that had the the fake wooden case
plastic right right the big giant it was
like the centerpiece of the of the of
your living room the big giant faux wood
tv set with the tube in there that
wasn't hd how did we enjoy
anything on tv before hd yes how far you
have come with all your nice plasma tvs
you have in your tv room now let's take
a break
of the week when pft live continues
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports